les enquêteurs qui commence également à
mieux cerner les activités du réseau et
bien avant l'enlèvement dylan on
découvre qu'un certain nombre de
personnalités ont été menacés victime de
chantage et d'extorsion de fonds comme
le pdg de la chaîne arte jérôme clément
ou encore l'ancien président de médecins
sans frontières rony brauman tous deux
ont été les cibles du gang ian frontier
arnauld miguet depuis plus de trois ans
youssef fofana et son entourage auraient
multiplié les tentatives d'extorsion de
fonds comme l'a révélé ce matin le
quotidien libération sous des noms
d'emprunt en utilisant par exemple le
sigle de groupes clandestins corses
il aurait tenté de racketter plusieurs
personnalités comme rony brauman ancien
président de médecins sans frontières
une enveloppe c'est vraiment votre
lettre qui contenait à la fois une
lettre me menaçant de mort
réclamant l'impôt révolutionnaire
puisque cette lettre était signée
d'armata corsa et on me demandait de
faire c'est plus de 300000 euros et
quelques mois plus tard à peu près même
épisode les mêmes même forme même l'être
même enveloppe mais cette fois ci
accompagné d'un coup de feu dans mon
portail et d'un g2 deux cocktails
molotov dans la cour de la maison les
mêmes menaces les mêmes tentative
d'intimidation jérôme clément le patron
d'arte et les a reçu lui aussi
accompagné d'une vidéo explicite
cassette vidéo représentaient des gens
cagoulés armés utilisant des bazookas
des mitraillettes et y rencontre des
cibles combrié pas en disant c'était
voilà ce qui va vous arriver si vous ne
versez pas la rançon
autre victime maître joseph cohen-sabban
at il été choisi à cause de ses origines
juives
l'avocat pénaliste s'interroge pourquoi
moi parce que je m'appelle cohen sabban
ce qui est l'étendard juifs par
excellence je m'appelle cohen sabban est
ce que c'est un cela qui a provoqué le
ciblage est ce ma fonction d'avocat ma
profession d'avocat les 2 séparent mais
rétrospectivement effectivement un seul
sentiment de prêts très désagréable
malaise sur la vingtaine de cibles
choisies par le groupe
toutes n'étaient pas juives mais tout
réside dans le sud de paris d'où est
originaire youssef fofana ainsi que ses
complices présumés
autre lien établi par la police dans
chaque affaire y compris le rapt et le
meurtre dylan une même cabine
téléphonique mm cybercafés ont été
utilisés